right
sweet baby gang
representing there good
got a lot of them in here so we got a
few sweet baby gang and then a lot of
confused people also
which is what it's all about so um thank
you so much for being here everybody
thank you to the western conservative
summit for having me you know
what i want to talk about is as you may
have noticed we live in a culture that
seems to have
completely lost its mind
we are living through a period of mass
psychosis that is very truly
unprecedented in the history of human
civilization
it seems as though all at once millions
of our countrymen
sort of woke up one day having forgot
some of the most basic facts about
reality like a giant epidemic of just
the weirdest sort of amnesia
and lying at the heart of this
intellectual chaos is the confusion or
apparent confusion anyway
over human biology
a a mental disease called gender
ideology has gripped hold of a large
swath of the american public
and totally taken over almost all of our
or in fact all of our most powerful
institutions
the disciples of this cult have been
convinced or pretend to be convinced
anyway that men are women women are men
that you know men can have babies women
can have penises that a woman can
impregnate a man who can then give birth
to and breastfeed a child
that somehow the most basic facts about
reality and about biology facts which
all people everywhere across the entire
world for thousands and thousands of
years all recognized intuitively
are no longer valid
it's total madness and it's a madness
which has infected our society and now
is threatening i think
to tear it apart at the seams already is
in fact doing that
it was for this reason that i along with
my
extraordinary team at the daily wire
decided that we had to make a film which
just premiered on the daily wire and has
angered the left so much that there was
even
and still is a sustained cyber attack on
the site to shut us down and prevent
people from seeing it
along with all the other tricks they're
they're pulling around this thing
the film is called what is a woman and
it documents
my year-long journey to confront and
expose gender ideology
uh it was a journey that took us all
over the the country from san francisco
to seattle to new york
many places in between
it took us even across the world deep
into the bush in kenya
took us to other third world countries
too like los angeles for example
now
our goal broadly was to
explore gender ideology to kind of show
it for what it is
and as the title suggests this larger
goal centers around one seemingly quite
simple and specific question what is a
woman
now back it up a few years it occurred
to me sometimes shortly after bruce
jenner became caitlyn
and was immediately declared woman of
the year
back in like 2015 i think it was
that the word woman ceases to have any
meaning if a guy named bruce can be
considered one
the word man too is emptied of all
meaning
it occurred to me also that this is a
major problem for the left for the
people promoting this agenda because if
the word woman no longer means adult
human female
then what does it mean
and the left
if they cannot tell us what it means
then how can they use the word
and if they cannot use the word then how
can they have women's marches and talk
about
women's rights or say anything else
about women if you don't know what the
word means
indeed how can a man say i identify as a
woman
if the word woman doesn't mean anything
isn't that about as meaningful as me
saying that i identify as a i don't know
a who's he what's it or a
flipper doodle
you say well what is that well that's
nothing
how can anyone identify as gibberish
and if they do identify as gibberish how
are we supposed to affirm or respect
that i couldn't affirm gibberish even if
i wanted to
and i don't want to
so it became obvious to me that this
question what is a woman presents an
insurmountable logical problem for the
left
and so i kept
asking the question and asking it and
asking it and asking it in every form
available to me for years and years
but they simply ignored the question to
the extent that they could
and carried on pretending like their
worldview was not fatally incoherent and
self-contradictory
well after years of this game of them
ducking and dodging the question the big
question what is a woman i finally
decided that uh it was time to take the
question
to them to sort of put it in front of
their faces confront them directly with
the incoherence of their beliefs
i could do that or i could just drop the
whole thing but i don't drop anything so
instead i decided to
travel across the entire world
and that began the quest that became the
film which is now available on
dailywire.com to watch we spoke to
alleged experts doctors therapists
professors surgeons we spoke to trans
people themselves we spoke to activists
we spoke to politicians
we spoke to average people on the street
we spoke to nomadic tribesmen living in
huts made out of cow dung
and those were the by far the sanest
voices that we that we came across in
the
in in the journey
we spoke to everybody who could who
would speak to us
surprisingly i only had to use a
bullhorn once
and i learned quite a bit through this
extraordinary and often bewildering and
uh
sometimes funny but often disturbing
adventure
some of what i learned was a revelation
for me other lessons
i sort of already knew so i had to
relearn them
and in either case it was enlightening
and just as i hope the film is
enlightening for the viewer
so what i want to do now is talk about
the i'd say five main lessons that i
learned or relearned
through the course of this project
and in researching the subject as we
went along
um i've spent basically a year fully
immersed in the most vile and toxic
lunacy that
the world has ever known and it has not
been good for my as they say these days
mental health
but i did learn uh these things at least
so number one
what i learned
is that gender ideology is totally
absolutely
pervasive
this is not as conservative sometimes
like to reassure themselves
strictly the province of gender studies
professors
and weirdos on tick tock
many of whom are gender studies
professors as it happens
the basic tenets of gender ideology
you know that gender is fluid that
people can decide for themselves whether
they're men or women
that transgenderism is a valid and
healthy state of being
which should be encouraged and affirmed
that sex is not binary that there are
dozens if not in infinity of valid
identities outside of man and woman
these beliefs however half-baked and
incoherent they may be
can be found everywhere in the country
stop any average person on the street
i've done it
no matter what they look like or how old
they are
and they are likely to talk about gender
in ways very similar to how a gender
studies professor would talk about it
they may not realize who they're
parroting but they are parrots
nonetheless and they don't even know it
they've adopted these beliefs or
pretended to and we'll return to that in
a minute the pretending part of it
now beyond the average adults walking
down any average sidewalk the most
powerful institutions are fully
enthralled
to this mania
this is particularly the case among the
medical pharmaceutical and psychological
industries and within education i talked
to a therapist who was ready to affirm
me as a woman because i confessed to
enjoying scented candles
in all seriousness
i did also mention in fairness that i've
seen sex in the city one time and so
that's what put me over the edge and she
said well you know that's a good
question maybe you're a woman
i talked to a pediatrician who refused
to even agree
that only female chickens lay eggs
and she would not agree with that
because she said she doesn't know a
chicken's gender identity
very very real
i talked to a college professor who
called me condescending and rude
because i use the word truth
now these people are not fringe within
the institutions they represent
they are utterly standard commonplace
this is what they're all like
and through these institutions these
ideas are fed to the public they're
dumped out onto the masses like a you
know giant uh sewage pipeline
children of course are most susceptible
as many children our country today are
indoctrinated into the gender cult
practically from birth
they're put on the the path to identity
crisis and mutilation and
despair
and oftentimes
suicide
before they're even out of diapers
they're exploited indoctrinated lied to
drugged
they are chemically castrated with drugs
that are meant for cancer patients
with drugs that we actually do give to
pedophiles and sex offenders to
chemically castrate them we give those
same drugs to 12 year old boys
now i i talked to a pediatrician as i
mentioned who gives these drugs to kids
and i and i asked her about this and um
i said well this same drug lupron that
you give to uh to kids isn't that used
to chemically castrate sex offenders
and she said um this interview is over
and threatened to get up and leave
although she she kept sitting for a
little while longer anyway and she she
proceeded to
lecture me and say that my questions
were malignant and harmful
just because i wanted to know more about
the drugs that she is prescribing to
children
quite a statement by the way malignant
and harmful coming from somebody who
castrates children for a living
the effect is now is that now trans
identification among the youngest
generations
has increased 20-fold over previous
generations
overall 20 percent of gen z identifies
as lgbt
20 now let's put that into perspective
among their grandparents generation
the number is point eight percent
in fact lgbt identification has almost
exactly doubled in every generation for
the past five generations in a row
and counting
this is all by design of course
our children face a very sophisticated
coordinated and vast
indoctrination campaign i'll never
forget the words that were said to me by
somebody named scott nugent who is a
woman who as an adult transitioned to a
man or rather transitioned to appear
like a man as she put it herself
in the documentary and her experiences
with transition have been hellish
they've been so bad in fact that the
complications from the surgeries
will one day kill her as she told me
now it's her mission to warn other
people against falling into the same
trap especially children and that's the
part that haunts me she said she said to
me
you know this got me at 42
your child doesn't stand a chance
and for many children she's right
the statistics prove it
keep in mind by the way that as the lgbt
club expands
generationally
it also expands alphabetically
adding new letters you know to the
acronym every single
day it seems
new categories of identity are invented
and immediately affirmed
in the film i interviewed a therapist
who was once trans affirming but has now
backed away from that approach because
she saw how far things were going
the depths
that we were sinking to
and she told me about kids in school who
identify as cats
and are thus affirmed as cats
animals
in the school system
i followed it up by by interviewing a
man who actually identifies as an animal
he identifies as a woman and also as a
wolf
now we laugh at the absurdity
because it is absurd
but then you realize what lies
underneath it
the second thing i learned is that
there's an immense amount of fear
driving all of this
i said that so many of the people i
encountered on the street appeared to be
confused
some of them actually were confused one
woman was particularly committed to the
relativistic view that we all have our
own truth
and i asked her um
well okay we all have our own truth what
would happen if if it was my truth
that you don't exist
and she looked me dead in the eyes and
she said that if i think she doesn't
exist
then she doesn't exist
and she was not joking
now i knew that women were being erased
in our culture that's part of the reason
i made the movie i didn't realize that
some women were so eager to erase
themselves
but more often i encountered people
whose confusion was more of a it was
more of a front it was it was an
affectation
they gave vague and dodgy answers to my
questions because they were afraid to
speak basic biological truths on camera
many refuse to say anything at all
telling me that if they that if they uh
you know if they talk about this issue
with the cameras rolling that it would
mean the loss of their job their friends
their family their reputation
to be clear their lives would be
destroyed if they said something like
only women can have babies
on camera
or any similarly provocative statement
gender ideology paves the way for itself
through
fear
with intimidation threats
coercion
the third point
that's very important
is that
none of this is new
um at least not as new as it may seem
the roots of ge of modern gender
ideology can be traced all the way back
to the 19th century in fact arguably
even earlier than that
but it really began to take its current
shape in the mid 20th century thanks to
the work of two hideously evil crackpots
named alfred kinsey and john money
these are names that everybody should
know and few people do
in the interest of time i'll focus on
john money for just a moment it's worth
looking into alfred kinsey though we
talk about him in the film a little bit
but an even deeper dive is worthwhile if
you do in fact do that make sure to have
a vomit bucket handy
as for john money he was a prominent
psychologist and sexologist and
one of the one of the early pioneers of
the gender theories that are currently
taught in grade schools and universities
he was among the first to take the word
gender
out of the realm of grammar
and apply it to people
because until him you know we never said
that people have a gender
well people have a sex and gender is
words have gender
but he said no no no people have gender
and sex
and he coined that he also coined the
terms gender role gender identity and
sexual orientation
suffice it to say he was an extremely
influential man and anybody who
propagates left-wing gender theory today
is repeating at least some of the ideas
of john money whether they know it or
not and most of them do not know it
that fat that fact i think ought to
trouble gender theory proponents because
john money was among other things
um a fraud and an abuser and a pedophile
jumping to 1965 the birth of twins bruce
and brian reimer
the boys are born healthy except for a
condition called phimosis which affects
the foreskin
and it was decided incorrectly it turns
out that the best way to treat the
condition was circumcision
but bruce's procedure went horribly
wrong and his penis was essentially
burned off
after several months of grasping for
answers bruce's parents eventually
decided to take him to johns hopkins in
baltimore to see the renowned
gender
surgeon dr john money
and the good doctor eager to prove the
legitimacy of his theory that gender is
a product of environment and culture
recommended that bruce undergo sex
reassignment surgery
so before the age of uh of two the deed
had been done his testicles were removed
some crude approximation of female
genitalia was formed and um
money instructed his parents to raise
him as a girl and said that well this
will work perfectly because
gender is a social construct so create a
social construct of femininity for him
and he will be a her and that will be it
happily ever after
well not so
the rhymer parents tried to follow
money's advice but they found that bruce
was still bruce even if they called him
brenda
it did everything in their power to
preserve his fragile and false female
identity
gender is a construct they were told
why should a boy raised as a girl still
have boyish tendencies
still ultimately money was convinced
that his project had been a smashing
success and he bragged of his triumphs
in many published works
but it was not a success
the female identity never took hold for
bruce he was confused and miserable and
on the verge of suicide
until as a teen his mother finally told
him the truth
bruce chose immediately to transition
back to a boy taking the name of david
uh he underwent another reassignment
surgery this time to try and reclaim his
true self
and he felt better for a time but
neither his brother nor himself lived
happily ever after
ultimately they both ended up committing
suicide
now their deaths go down in history as
suicides but they were both effectively
murdered by john money who's the father
of modern
gender theory
and that's the birth of gender ideology
as we know it today it was born
in abuse and despair and death
and that is what it has reaped ever
since
number four the ultimate goal of gender
ideology
goes far beyond gender
a word which has been expanded you know
into oblivion
anyway
the ultimate goal is to undermine
destroy erase
truth itself
leftism is relativism and relativism is
the belief that there is no objective
truth no shared reality no universal
facts that we all have to conform
ourselves around and submit ourselves to
the relativist claims the right to
invent his own universe for himself
right even to the point of inventing
himself
he seeks to be a self-created being
making and remaking himself as he sees
fit down to the very biological level
he believes that his ego
overrides all else
everything must bow before it language
institutions science even his own dna
this is why i found myself speaking to
pontius pilate over and over again what
is truth the gender ideologues would ask
who's truth which truth are we talking
about
i was sitting in the same room as them
but they would not agree that we were
situated in the same reality
they get their own reality they insisted
and that ultimately is what this all is
all about it's about having your own
reality
but here's the good news finally number
five the final thing i learned from
spending a year staring into this abyss
is that we can win this fight
gender ideology is insane destructive
pervasive ubiquitous
and beatable
you know i get sure
i get um i get asked this
all the time
you know is this a hill that i'm really
gonna that i want to die on do you want
to die on this hill
and the answer is yes i'll die on this
hill
if there's any hill worth dying on it's
this one
the hill of objective truth yeah i think
that's pretty important
i'll die on that
but uh but though i'm willing to die on
this hill i i don't plan on it as
general patton said back in the days
before the military cared about equity
intolerance more than killing bad guys
he said uh no bastard ever won a war by
dying for his country he won it by
making some other poor dumb bastard die
for his
well
i would say the same metaphorically for
this hill this fight for truth this
struggle against gender lunacy we can
win because the other side can be
crushed under the weight of simple
questions i saw this happen myself
before my very eyes time and time again
the learned the educated the experts
crumpled and collapsed and panicked
in front of me just this bumpkin wearing
flannel with a armed with a high school
diploma
running out of the room
is it because i'm brilliant
well those are my preferred adjectives
that's how i identify myself but
um no i don't have to be brilliant
fortunately
all you need to do is just stand up and
look this thing directly in the face
serve it a healthy dose of skepticism
force it to explain itself
the gender ideologues are weak and
scared and vulnerable they've perched
themselves on a limb that isn't even
connected to a tree they're anchored in
nothing
their worldview is empty and frail and
flimsy
we don't need to be armed with anything
but a spine
enough to stand up against them straight
just stand up straight and ask questions
questions that cannot be answered
questions that for that reason aren't
supposed to even be asked
but we must ask them
and if we do we'll win
and we must win also
that's it for me guys thank you
appreciate it
thank you
god bless
please welcome back jeff hunt
thank you matt walsh i watched the movie
last night a really incredible film make
sure you go to